where does it come from boris johnson on
the campaign trail in wales
but ten days out from an election the pm
struggling to bat away damaging leaks
and revelations
there is so much he doesn't want to talk
about
such as dominic cummings allegation that
the pm's plan to pay for number 10 flat
renovations
was possibly illegal the unfolding
lobbying scandal engulfing former prime
minister david
cameron and even boris johnson himself
and explosive claims mr johnson said
he'd rather let the bodies pile high
than order a third lockdown not the sort
of press you want as voters head to the
polls
the pm insists the public don't much
care
i'm finding that a lot of this stuff
that you're that people are talking
about is actually not what's
uh coming up on the on the doorstep or
the issues that people are raising
uh with what people want to know about
is what is the government doing to get
on
uh with our agenda to unite and level up
across the country
but the opposition enjoying this and
trying to ratchet
up the pressure what i want is a full
and transparent investigation into
everything that's going on we've got
lots of investigations going on but we
haven't got anything that's looking at
the pattern of behavior
and day after day there are new
allegations of sleaze
of favors of privileged access and those
allegations are made
more dangerous and damaging because
they're coming not from boris johnson's
political opponents
but his wants most trusted ally and
closest aid
on the politics it puts labour on the
attack and the prime minister
on the back foot just days from the
country going
to the polls and on the substance it
raises
serious questions about the conduct
ethics
and culture of boris johnson's
government
the head of the civil service is
currently investigating a series of
leaks from number 10.
he may not identify the culprit but
culture could be the cause the culture
is absolutely vital
i can assure you that cabinet
cabinet ministers officials permanent
and
temporary are very regularly reminded of
their
obligations
for now tory mps are holding their noses
and looking the other way
but it's true too that the party backed
boris johnson because he was a vote
winner
may the sixth will test whether the mud
sticks and the mood towards the pm
darkens beth rigby sky news westminster